Today we have something extra special for you guys,...
...and you guys will be some of the first people outside of our team...
...and outside of Google to ever ride in it.
Oh, there it is!
Isn't that cute?
There's no steering wheel in the way.
It was a big decision for us to go and start building our purpose-built vehicles first...
...and really they're prototype vehicles.
They were a chance for us to explore...
...what does it really mean to have a self-driving vehicle.
But in the small amount of time we've been working on it,...
...now we have functional prototypes and that's exciting.
Oh, it's really cool!
It was really kind of a space-age experience.
We're like queens.
You sit, relax, you don't have to do nothing.
It knows when it needs to stop, it knows when it needs to go.
It actually rides better than my own car.
Yes, it's true.
What she really liked was that it slowed down before it went around a curve...
...and then accelerated in the curve.
She's always trying to get me to do it that way.
That's the way I learned in a high school driver's ed.
So, if I had a self-driving car, I could spend more time hanging out with my kids...
...or helping them with their homework,...
...even just tending to them, finding out how their day was...
...and not having to wait 'til you get home and have dinner and all that...
...so it'll be good.